depuis plus de 40 ans qu'elle peint à la
main le journaliste robert fisk parcours
le moyen-orient il a couvert la guerre
au liban en syrie en irak en afghanistan
la guerre iran irak
le film intitulé des cessna de nos vie
du réalisateur canadien yuncheng retrace
le parcours de ceux correspondant de
guerre avaient été ré je suis
journaliste et c'est mon travail c'est
mon devoir de dire la vérité seulement
l'histoire des pays au moyen orient se
construit surtout dans la violence dit
il il témoigne dans ses articles de
cette histoire qui se déroule sous ses
yeux le moyen orient ce n'est pas si
complexe
si vous avez la justice pour tous les
peuples par le dictateur pas l'élégant
d'américains qui est qui est de les
dictateurs dash n'existe pas ou n'existe
pas al qaïda n'existe pas il son
éducation son justice vous avez une
société qui vivent dont le peur de la
mort et en anarchie
selon lui il faudrait troqué les armes
pour des livres je dis toujours si c'est
possible de données au moyen orient par
les one man band et paris donnent par
les grandes avions hélicoptères donné le
peuple des universités séculaire
ce n'est pas si cher comme les âmes basé
à beyrouth depuis 1976 il écrit pour le
quotidien indépendant de londres tout la
jeunesse de tous les religions dans le
centre de beyrouth
ils ont demandé pas la résignation le
retrait du gouvernement mais une système
constitutionnel qui n'est pas cette
carrière confessionnelles et c'est le
seul métier auquel c'est possible au
liban dépend donné la corruption
d'abandonner les comptes élite 2 ohama
en arabe round fils est un des rares
journalistes occidentale avoir
interviewé osama ben laden à trois
reprises le dernier interview c'est pour
moi le plus importante parce que ils
commencent deux
de parler leur future prend ici mon idée
il voulait être le roi d'arabie
il affirme que la haine de ben laden
envers les américains s'est développée
quand les états unis ont installé une
base militaire en arabie saoudite un
lieu sacré pour les musulmans et six ans
avant le 11 septembre 2001 il y fait
cette révélation
je pris au bon dieu qu'il nous permette
permis de bouleverser les états unis
aujourd'hui il constate qu'à l'ère de
l'internet de moins en moins de
journalistes en sur le terrain il est
très difficile de prouver des faits et
selon lui la vérité est compromise et
fut donc gauche dessine
trop de pubs on a dit qu'il n'y a alors
est ce que ces reportages font une
différence je ne crois pas que c'est
possible d'avoir la puissance de changer
le monde
peut-être de temps en temps nous
ouvrions les portes d'une prison
peut-être à 73 ans il est toujours aussi
passionné il n'est pas près de fermer
son calepin
il célèbre de l'eger 10 radio canada
montréal